[Aplausos]
una marea humana que buscaba atravesar
el cerco de las fuerzas de seguridad
guatemaltecas
los agentes respondieron con bastones
gases lacrimógenos y una granada de
aturdimiento hasta que los migrantes
retrocedieron la cuidad
los hechos se produjeron en el
departamento de chiquimula fronterizo
con honduras guatemala desplegó a 5000
soldados y a miles de agentes de la
policía civil en siete departamentos del
país para frenar el avance de los
migrantes que hacen parte del último
grupo de la caravana que partido desde
san pedro sula la semana pasada y que
busca llegar a eeuu los caminantes se
encuentran bloqueados desde la noche del
sábado
el camino de los migrantes que huyen de
la violencia la crisis del coi 19 y la
destrucción de los huracanes
etayo está se encuentra plagado de
obstáculos al inicio habilitado con
miedo pero no ya al ver la gente
desmotivada que todos alegres unidos y
todo pues
ya me iba perdiendo el miedito gracias a
dios ya pasamos lo que es la primera
parte de guatemala y si dios lo permite
pues pasaremos más allá y todo concepto
se hace
méxico también reforzó la presencia de
las autoridades en la frontera que
precisamente ya bloqueó el paso de
cientos de personas que buscaban
ingresar de manera irregular por el río
suchiate que marca la frontera con
guatemala aunque no sean parte de la
caravana
los caminantes se encuentran
esperanzados con el cambio de gobierno
de eeuu pues yo vaivén ha insinuado que
se necesita un enfoque más humano en
materia migratoria no obstante la
agencia reuters sitúa un funcionario de
la nueva administración que pidió a los
ciudadanos que se abstengan de realizar
la peligrosa travesía